[Music]
ready all right ready right
good evening Development Committee 25th
of January 2018 everyone here is
familiar with the venue does anyone need
me to read the emergency evacuation
instructions to them no thank you
so item 1 apologies for absence have
been received from councilor mountain
who's been substituted by councillor
mrs. Mason councillor Newport who's been
kept substituted by council Rotem thank
you there are no substitute no non
members attending so minutes of the
meeting on the 11th of January 2018
we've got the minutes ready to be signed
however accounts the hoc way you made
some comments they are appropriately in
I believe that the officers have been
copying you into emails and as stated
the rest of this matter is being dealt
with obviously outside the meeting are
you happy with that would you like to
add yes Thank You chairman um yes I have
read the minutes so I'm happy with what
is in there and as I understand it when
we spoke at the end of last meeting you
said that it will be the February
meeting that we're likely to get
something back in relation to the
Auditor it's it's it's an ongoing
process I believe that obviously not
connecting with the accuracy of the
minutes but there's a meeting to be
arranged with the developer mr strannix
is in process of dealing with that and
really you've been kept in contact but
we're looking for February meeting for a
short statement back on the progress of
that item yes thank you yes that's the
mrs. Mason
yes we can do we can do that's not a
problem other than that members you're
happy for the minutes to be signed okay
thank you
declarations of interest do we have any
now thank you
right item six the only item that's with
us tonight the deferred item from last
time Halcyon Park Falls laying home
bridge just a reminder that there is an
amount of information on the addendum
and I believe everyone's had that
circulated to them and seen it okay
thank you very much mr. Strang she's
going to lead us on this one
like would you just mind clicking your
mark again please that's it thank you
just to rephrase chairman the central
part of the site is in a predominantly
residential use where the existing
access is and members can see from this
layout that the applicants are in the
process of expanding the recreation or
accommodation on the site and the
proposal that was before members at the
last committee was for a second access
at this point here off Kingsman Farm
Road and members were concerned about
the visibility given the hedgerows and
things we see some photographs in a
minute but members will also recall that
one of the issues that has since been
resolved was the nature of the crossing
into the site there's a small ditch here
that needed to be culvert 'add and part
of the history of the application has
been that this cross section here the
Environment Agency were not prepared to
have obstructed and the application was
redesigned to form this sort of
letterbox style approach and that the
area roughly proportion into that
roughly equates to the area there so
that the potential for blockage et
cetera has been overcome such that
you'll see from the report the
Environment Agency have removed their
upholding objection that they held now
here is the revised access arrangement
you'll see here and if we go to the top
of the screen you'll see that they've
included some sweat path details to show
that the access functioning with toad
caravans you'll see that a typical
vehicle and a touring Caravan attached
behind you'll see that they've provided
these swept path movements into and out
of the site to demonstrate how the
access works
now after the debate that members held
and you'll see from these photographs of
supplied by members looking at the
hedgerows either side and the relevant
visibility that members asked for
officers to go back to the highway
Authority with the request that did they
actually appreciate the difficulties on
the site there was the concern that
perhaps in this case highways officers
at practice relied on Google and weren't
familiar with the site now you'll see on
the addendum there is the letter from
the applicant that rehearses some of the
other issues to do with a site that was
on the last addendum but on the second
page you'll see that the highway
Authority have replied back to
yourselves to explain the process and
the dates and time scales that went into
their visit you'll see that they
undertook a site visit on the 12th of
May given the age of this application
and then it goes into explain how they
approached that site visit the
observations that they made and then a
further discussion between the officer
herself as well as the highways engineer
and that highways engineer has been a
lead officer giving you highways advice
for many years and then they went on to
check the collision record data found no
record of incidents and then came to the
view which is the view that you have
before you and I articulated in my
presentation that whilst I think members
might be surprised at that
recommendation
the highways officers felt that because
of the nature of this street which I
think is giving members concerns they
anticipated and saw themselves that
vehicles were passing at such a slow
rate that the prospect of of accident or
damage and hitting each other was
greatly reduced because of these
circumstances and that's why you have a
recommendation perhaps surprising to
some that the development will function
and work and as the agent has shown with
the the sweat path movements and
therefore the Highways Authority raised
no objection now hopefully that analysis
that set out on the addenda
helps members and delivers on the on the
questions asked of officers so to to
bring it to a conclusion chairman the
recommendation from officers is one of
approval subject to the conditions set
out in the report and you will see that
those conditions repeat the specific
conditions asked for by the County
Highway Authority Thank You counselor
mrs. hoy okay just turn your mic thank
you even though this and I understand
that there are no grounds for refusal
[Music]
and if I did recommend it for a few
thought it would win on an appeal anyway
so I on I understand that or whether
from advice from officers you can't
argue with secretary consul T sort of
being because I always get it right
well they don't always get it right so I
would like moccasins noted and the fact
that it's hi we haven't produced any
evidence of traffic driving slow down
there and that's all I really wanted to
say thank you thank you
how's the mrs. Mason Thank You mr.
chairman my belief is that there is a
protocol that exists between Essex
County Council or inside Essex County
Council that when they are giving a
report on a highway situation they
should indicate whether they are not a
site visit had taken place and I think
that was part of the concern that this
detail was not available
in January however as Kalamazoo's hoy
has said there are no planning reasons
to refuse this especially in light of
the additional information
however in fear of the concerns
expressed and I said this is not a
planning issue but I do think that it
might be an approach might be considered
to the local highway panel by Ward
members for a speed restriction which
might alleviate some of the concern that
said on the information that I have in
front of me and with the clarification
that Essex County Council did in fact
visit the site I can only move this for
approval okay now it's a snap to
[Music]
a couple of points clarification
adjacent to the entrance there there's
quite a thick and high hedge is that
correct y-yeah is that in the control of
the applicant so it would be possible
for us to ask the applicant to sort of
cut that back to improve the visual
access there
keep coming
[Music]
that is actually in the highways office
that's the hawk way Thank You chairman
just like to ask the officer is I
haven't noticed it in the report and as
to whether it's part of any of the
conditions and maybe it's not something
that is part of this particular process
but has the highway of 40 indicated as
to whether there be providing any
additional signage to warm traffic users
of the the the new entrance chairman
I've need to check the conditions but I
don't I don't recall that being one of
the recommended conditions no it's not
that's a Stanley Thank You chairman two
things that come to mind at the moment
is that because of caravans having four
wheels two axles instead of just the one
axle is the depth of that entrance guide
to be sufficient for the larger caravans
where our notice you've only got a small
caravan which is probably only a to
birth size and also the comfort is what
necessary safety features are you
putting on the culvert for children not
getting underneath there and so on
please I think this proposal is for
static site so it's not not tore as I
don't think this is a visited as the
entrance point for the for the initial
delivery of vehicles children getting
under the culvert
yeah
it's no more dangerous than the cold
it's okay we'll come back on that CATSA
Wilson thanks a council Stanley actually
asked the question I was going to which
is about their yeah about the large size
of the the caravans that was all okay
height of a piece of a4 approximately
there abouts yes an L just a short
comment I'd like to support the comments
about signage and the speed limit
there's a real common-sense thing to
have particularly with a caravan park
and you will in the summer months have
kids riding bikes and all sorts of
things coming out of there it might be
for an appropriate member here to raise
it at the local highways panel I think
did you want to come back final talk
outside
thank you German just like to ask the
officer in relation to the fact that
there is nothing would seem to be in the
conditions in relation to additional
signage is it something that the
committee could then request or asked
for as a condition I think the Highways
Authority haven't asked for it I daresay
the the owner of the site may be
inclined to indicate where that
particular entrance is and though
whether there's restrictions with
placing signage on the highway I think
the the appropriate place for that is is
the Highways panel to discuss what's
there it wouldn't be normal to put that
in a planning condition as such high on
a relatively simple application we've
has a lot of speakers and a lot of
points raised already the the approval
is printed with its various conditions
on page six point one five and six point
one six
could I ask that those members in favor
of approval please indicate
Thank You those against okay I'll just
say that items carried on that boat yeah
glad just affirmed can I just say that
I'm abstaining and I'm not my vote we
called you the other day you didn't vote
so he can't abstentions okay that's
meeting done then thank you very much
[Music]